once again this weekend the women
marched and once again they had nothing
to say we will dismantle the women's
March point by point then Allie Stuckey
and amber Athey joined the panel of
deplorable z-- to discuss feminism the
45th anniversary of roe v wade the
pointless government shutdown how
technology is leading to unhappiness and
further evidence that donald trump is
boosting the global economy
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael nul show
[Music]
so by what I have to assume as divine
providence
I spent the women's March in pre-cana
marriage counseling with my fiance sweet
little ELISA actually sitting next to a
guy named Jesus I turned to my right and
there's a guy just named Jesus he
pronounced it differently but sitting
right there in pre marriage counseling
so while the shrieking harpies yelled
about nothing downtown I learned about
how women actually are empowered and I
just wanted to share a few takeaways
because it was pretty good
so one well feminism preaches about the
Equality of the sexes women's
empowerment you'll notice it only values
masculine traits you know assertiveness
aggression casual sex it leaves women
generally unfulfilled and used so you
see this especially in the hook-up
culture so in the hook-up culture you
know women are encouraged to view sex
and exactly the same way that men view
sex so men went frequently I don't want
to tell any tales at a school men go out
and they try to have sex and casual sex
is much more common for men so women are
told you have to do that you have to
value that too and if women don't value
casual sex if they don't feel fulfilled
from it they're told that something is
wrong with them
this obviously leads to men just doing
whatever they please and it's very nice
for men but it's an ironic effect of
feminism and a Christian marriage on the
other hand sacramental marriage on the
other hand is predicated on the Equality
of the sexes on the equal dignity of the
sexes in the beginning God created man
both male and female he created them Eve
comes from Adam's rib and Adam says bone
of my bone you are flesh of my flesh and
the rib here is important because he
doesn't come from Adams skull from his
head she's not above at him she doesn't
come from Adam's foot she isn't from his
toe she's not below him
she's from his rib she's she has equal
dignity men and women have equal dignity
from the very beginning and so there you
have a real equality of the sexes but a
complimentary equality so in civil
marriage and non-christian marriage non
sacramental marriage civil marriage is a
dis all Yubel contract that either party
can break so when men get tired they can
move on they can find a younger wife and
they can leave women who have become
less sexually desirable often less
professionally capable high and dry
usually leave them in custody of the
children that they need to feed and
because sacramental marriage is an oath
taken before God that cannot be broken
one phrase that was used as you
shouldn't make a fool of God and as the
the spouses go grow closer together they
grow closer to God like an equal at
equilateral triangle so as they move
closer to God they move closer to one
another at the pre marriage counseling
they didn't harp too much a natural
family planning commonly referred to as
pull and pray which I sort of expected
them to do I was expected they'd say
have kids immediately you have a
gazillion kids right now but they did
point out that marriage which is from
the beginning closed off to even the
possibility of procreation that we don't
want to have kids we just want to have a
nice beach house or something that isn't
valid in the eyes of the church we have
to be open to life into giving life and
to giving love even not everyone's going
to have kids not everyone can have kids
but there's a there's a sense of viewing
the marriage which is that it has to be
open to life that I think is widely
throughout the culture is not the case
in the United States especially after
this sexual revolution but the church
still views it that way they and it's
very affirming and it's very life-giving
so as we were learning all of this sweet
little ELISA and I across town in
downtown LA the shrieking harpies were
marching to end life through abortion I
guess I guess those are the most
coherent signs really I don't think they
had any idea what they were protesting
flicka's talks friend of the show he
went out there to check it out here's
what he saw basically everything that he
stands on as a platform to be honest
what do you disagree with Trump so far
well I tried for a lot of time so about
five years so a lot of negativity
towards the tribes
[Music]
what is like the number one reason
whenever everyone's here pull my hair
with Margaret NAT well what brings you
here today
everything they had nothing to say what
are you here for I don't know I'm not
sure yeah absolutely nothing to say the
historian David McCullough
observed that to write well is to think
clearly which is why it's so hard but
they can't write well they can't put a
sentence together because they don't
know what they're there for they aren't
thinking clearly they're seeing a lot of
people out and they're marching and we
know that it should be marching we
should feel things what are you there
for you know just to be it to empower
and to come out and I know no idea it's
just foggy meaningless thinking this is
incredible the New York Times listed the
best quotes from the most articulate
women's marchers that it could find here
is the creme de la creme of the aimless
shrieking harpies the first court they
use one thing I hope for women in 2018 I
want us to prove that we can we are here
we know we can do it now we are here to
stay that was a 36 year old woman who
said that Amelia Paz the amazing thing
with all of these quotes you'll see is
you can't tell which of them were said
by six-year-olds and which of them were
said by 36 year olds but consider every
single word that was just said there we
are here wait no one ever said you
weren't here no one ever I promise you
no one ever thought you weren't here we
may we know that the women are here
they're more than half of the country
that we can we know you can do a lot of
things no one there they're reacting not
only to problems that don't exist or to
to quite no one ever said you're not
here or you can't do something or
whatever they're they're not even making
a point they're just saying words that
sound like they mean something but they
don't really mean anything they're just
words as
would say words words words mashed up
together that don't have any
significance another quote there is
power in numbers
we all have different reasons for being
here but we are all here to educate
ourselves and empower each other it is
an honor to be here
that was a 19 year old named summer now
they don't they don't actually have
different reasons at all for being here
it's all the same thing and it's
unreason it does note there is no reason
there are different ones though I'm here
for this I'm here for that it's the same
totally vague platitudinous nothing and
now that woman went on she said it felt
like such an important moment in history
and that's the key here
that's the key to this whole protest the
whole women's March it isn't about
anything it just seems like something
important it has the look of a real
protest movement like say the civil
rights movement or john brown's raids so
the abolition movement it looks like
that but it isn't that they just want to
seem like activists but they don't want
anything because they have everything
another quote I hope women keep coming
together for positive movements in 2018
there was a 22 year old named shimmy me
Branch
I hope women keep coming together for
positive no that doesn't mean anything
obviously doesn't mean anything but
Shamima you'll note isn't even marching
for positive movements or whatever that
is she's there to get extra credit for
her gender studies class her Gender
Studies class offered her credit to go
to this thing and then she repeated the
platitude she heard that means that this
is being encouraged by the culture by
institutions
this isn't countercultural it isn't
subversive it's it's part of the
cultural orthodoxy to oppose the women's
March is to contravene the orthodoxy of
political correctness it could put your
career in jeopardy this is real-life
hashtag slacktivism signifying nothing
other than one's own performed virtue
but it's in real life it's moved off of
Twitter into real life but it's just as
empty it's just as vapid the next quote
I believe that women are the key to
world peace and justice I'm hoping that
all women infuse their organizations
with the common good because that's what
we need for our country fill a blank 88
years old you have no idea what that
means
Expo in 2018 we want girls to stay
strong and be confident in what they can
do the more we stand together the more
that we can do together now I know that
sounds like all of the other quotes you
just heard that was from an 11 year old
girl and that's fine if an 11 year old
girl wants to say something that doesn't
really mean anything and is just kind of
muddy thinking that's fine that's what
11 year olds do trouble is the 50 year
olds is saying the same thing the 11
year olds are just as articulate as the
50 year olds what's the next one I hope
that women fill up a whole lot of
offices that's what it'll take to turn
this around we need to step up to the
plate and do it that was less articulate
than any 11 year old the 11 year old
made much more sense as Beverly may 59
years old
and she said it seems like every day is
an assault on my soul with what comes
out in Washington the dismantling of our
democracy blah blah blah blah blah
doesn't she can't point to anything in
particular of course just the just the
feeling that's all the fields man next
quote I hope for fair representation and
more women in government I think that's
where change will happen so you hear in
all of these quotes as a 43 year old who
said that just as meaningless as the 11
year old they're all about change so
they're all saying we need to change we
need to change things what change what
change do you want what are you hoping
for
there isn't any clear chant we just had
8 years of Barack Obama the most
left-wing administration in modern
American history we've had we've got
Europe but we've elected your candidates
for years what change do you want
nothing just perpetual change that's
what we need next what I'm participating
because education is the only cure for
ignorance I believe women know
compassion and kindness and love and
empathy more than men that was a man
that was a 26 year old man who said that
unfortunately these days education seems
to be the cause of ignorance rather than
the solution of it next quote I want
everyone to become equal it's like we're
living in the 1920s and it is ridiculous
we need freedom for all that was a
20-year old Rebecca Logan she's right
because the stock market is really high
our culture is really decadent that is
true in a way it is
a lot like the 1920s unfortunately
people here are not only politically and
philosophically ignorant they're
historically ignorant as well there's
this common perception among the lightly
educated the Millennials that the past
was uniformly just those bad olden days
before the goodness of modernity and
this is the heart of the progressive
vision of the world you hear it
throughout the change we need the change
and the this and that the progressive
vision of the world is that we're always
getting better we're going toward
progress and sometimes people who are
either stupid or evil try to stand in
the way of progress those people are
conservatives but we know where progress
is and that's why we have to be changing
we can't be happy with what we have we
can't count our blessings because we're
not at utopia yet we're gonna go back to
the Garden of Eden
d'arnot we are we have not been kicked
out of perfection human nature is
perfectible but of course that isn't
true and they can't that's all they can
say right because they can't articulate
quite what they want quite what is wrong
is just something another woman said
we're three generations my mother my
daughter and me it's incumbent upon us
as women to stand up and represent
things are not gonna change if we don't
become the instruments of the change so
you hear the change that is all just
about change as a 51 year old who said
that
but the standing is important here to
the stand
Michael Oakshott rights in rationalism
and politics that the rationalist is
always standing you just standing yeah
they can't do anything because they
they're they're so far and their own
abstractions that they don't realize
that real life takes place in time and
space and with flesh so they just have
to stand so she's standing for change
whatever that means next well I'm
marching because I want women to
continue fighting and for the
conversation to be more inclusive of the
transgender community that was a Joe of
a lace 28 whose stage name is Beatrix
and who is from Brownsville Joe is a man
this is an irony of the
intersectionality stuff is that now a
men are choosing to just call themselves
women and then they get to take over the
women's march and now there's no purpose
to the women's March cuz it's a man's
March next well we need to stand up not
only for our choices but for everyone
else's choices even if we disagree we
have to accept each other and respect
each other and meet in the middle okay
next one said I chose this sign this
the last one I chose this sign because
the term angry black woman is so heavily
stigmatized and I want black women in
2018 to know they're allowed to feel the
widest amount of human emotions and that
includes anger because anger inspires
impactful change anger inspires
impactful change the word impactful is
that isn't a real word but people said
this is it's it's like the quintessence
of meaningless sloganeering it was a
word that was invented in the 1960s it
doesn't mean anything and that's that
that quote really sums it all up it's
just about feelings we need to feel
things and then the feeling is going to
vaguely do something but but not really
do anything it's impactful clickhole did
a parody of this kind of slacktivism a
couple of years ago but now the culture
has transcended parody here is a clip
that could be an advertisement for the
women's March I always wanted to be part
of something bigger than myself
to make a difference you go through life
and you see all this injustice but you
never really do anything about it you
don't know how I have two little kids so
I'm always thinking about their future
after solution begins with just one
person stepping up and taking
responsibility that's why I'm taking the
pledge I'm dating the plenty because I
care about my community for my kids my
grand for you for me for us for us for
them and for me too because I care about
the future and not just my future but
the future of everyone
every single person my baby boys taking
the pledge is about standing up for what
matters right it doesn't matter if
you're black white Muslim Christian and
Jewish anyone can take the pledge I got
my brother to take the pledge and he got
a spread to do it I got everyone in mice
you get her to take the pledge and she
gets someone else to get someone else
and on and on and on and suddenly we've
got something which bigger than anyone
Foss you take the pledge and you're part
of a global movement of people who
believe in change this is big I can feel
it can you feel it you go online and you
see these little videos of all around
the world people taking the pledge and
sharing it with their friends and it's
inspiring
my name is you a and I'm taking the
pledge Packard my god sucks mess with me
do you know I'm getting the pledge I'm
taking the pledge it's easy to be
cynical but I really do believe it's
possible to change the world wake up
people it's 2015 we can freakin do this
that could have been the advertisement
for the women's March just a meaningless
is nothing it doesn't get any better by
the way on the women's March website
here is the mission statement from
women's March calm the mission of
women's March is to harness the
political power of diverse women in
their communities to create
transformative social change women's
March is a women led movement providing
intersectional education on a diverse
range of issues and creating entry
points for new grassroots activists and
organizers to engage in their local
communities through trainings outreach
programs and events women's March is
committed to dismantling systems of
oppression through nonviolent resistance
and building inclusive structures guided
by self-determination dignity and
respect what what what what does any of
that mean they get a bit more as a
specific later on but this just shows
you how to how out of touch they are the
first principle that they list is ending
violence they right women deserve to
live full and healthy lives free of all
forms of violence against our bodies
just to correct the record here women
live significantly longer than men on
average by the end of the 20th century
the u.s. male life expectancy was
seventy three point four years compared
to eighty point one years for women
unlike men when women register to vote
they don't simultaneously have to
register for the military draft men are
far more likely to be the victims of
violent crime than we
76.8% of murder victims are male boys
and men are far more likely than girls
and women to be victims of assault and
robbery as well additionally according
to the Gallup World poll women report
being happier with their lives than
their male counterparts women's March
con goes on to the euphemistically
titled reproductive rights they say we
believe in reproductive freedom we do
not accept any federal state or local
rollback cuts or restrictions on our
ability to access quality reproductive
health care services birth control
hiv/aids prevention or medically
accurate sexuality education this means
open access to safe legal affordable
abortion and birth control for all
people so it's all it's just about
abortion they put all that other stuff
there but it's really about abortion and
yet according to a 2016 Marist Poll
despite constant Democrat euphemisms
renaming abortion as women's issues or
reproductive health nationally the vast
majority of women 77 percent support
restricting abortion to at most the
first trimester far fewer just 71
percent of men support restrictions on
abortion the the women are clearer the
majority of women 59% say abortion is
morally wrong 52% of women believe that
abortion should at most at most be
permitted in cases of rape incest were
to save the life of the mother but
nevertheless according to the women's
March women want abortion on demand
anytime anyplace that just isn't backed
up by reality on workers rights women's
March comm declares we believe in an
economy powered by transparency
accountability of security and equity
all women should be paid equitably and
you hear this constantly this popular
disinformation that there's a gender pay
gap women make 77 cents on the dollar no
equal pay for equal work
but that gender pay gap disappears once
you control for factors like education
time in the industry and hours worked
actually single childless women in
metropolitan areas they don't earn less
than their male counterparts they earn
more than their male counterparts by 8%
on average nationally women also
graduate from college at significantly
higher rates than men in 2015
39% of women 25 to 29
I had earned a bachelor's degree
compared to just 32 percent of men on
civil rights women's March comm explains
we believe civil rights are our
birthright including voting rights this
is odd to pick a fight on voting rights
as according to the Center for American
women and politics since 1980 women have
voted at higher rates in every single
presidential election than men so by
2016 that gap widened to sixty three
point three percent of women voting
compared to just fifty nine point three
percent of men additionally the number
of female voters has exceeded the number
of male voters in every presidential
election since 1964
despite constituting a majority of the
u.s. population
50.8% to forty nine point two percent
women also benefit from affirmative
action policies on campus and in the
workplace that give them a competitive
advantage over men there's a section on
disability rights women's March comprar
claims we believe that all women's
issues are issues faced by women with
disabilities and deaf women I guess that
one's right that's right I guess that
yes that's very deaf women or still
women I don't know what the point of
that is but sure that is that's the one
thing that the women's March got right
deaf women are women on immigrant rights
women's marched out calm insists rooted
in the promise of America's call for
huddled masses yearning to breathe free
we believe in immigrant and refugee
rights regardless of status or country
of origin we believe migration is a
human right and that no human being is
illegal so putting aside for a moment
the illogic of a national policy to do
away with national borders even on the
numbers the women's March doesn't seem
to represent women even among illegal
aliens brought to the United States as
children and teenagers even the dreamers
the most sympathetic and relentlessly
demagogue group of illegal aliens a
November survey from morning consult and
Politico shows that fewer than 30
percent of Americans support amnesty
even among Democrats support for
granting amnesty to the most sympathetic
group of illegal aliens is just 44%
finally at last segment on environmental
justice women's March comm observes we
believe that every person in every
community in our nation has the right to
clean water clean air and access to an
enjoyment of public lands
lucky for them federal law has protected
all of those things to say nothing of
state and local management for at least
the past five decades the women's March
is the most frivolous protest in the
history of the world to discuss we bring
on two women who are not frivolous Allie
Stuckey and amber Athey but first before
I can talk to these brilliant and
beautiful women I've got to talk about
Skillshare I've got to keep the lights
on in here folks this is a wonderful
thing so some people all they want to do
is complain that they can't get ahead
they can't make more money they can't
learn anything they can't start a new
career whatever and then other people
are just productive and they just do it
Skillshare calm is the best way to do
this so you know what I've talked about
this before this isn't the first time
we've talked about Skillshare but I love
it so it's January you're probably
thinking about your New Year's
resolution if you haven't broken it
already it's gonna late January so
usually most of those are gone by now
but while many people have resolved to
go on a diet you know start shedding for
the wedding as I need to do before my
tuxedo fitting hit the gym call mom more
often Skillshare encourages listeners to
use 2018 to learn new skills and make
this year their best year yet
so Skillshare calm is great it's an
online learning platform with over
18,000 classes and design business
technology more for me it's very hard
for me to manage my time really well I
get pulled in a lot of different
directions obviously I always need to
finish my stogies and I gotta sleep at
least 27 hours a day so it's very hard
to fit things in they're great classes
on Skillshare about time management how
to be more productive whether you're
trying to deepen your professional skill
set start a side hustle because it's
2018 and you're not just gonna work at
the plant for 60 years anymore and get a
pension you need to have a lot of
different skills and be ready for a
modern economy or you just want to start
something new
Skillshare will keep you learning in
2018 and beyond
so just in time for this new year I'm
loving I'm taking a few classes but the
most important one is time management
because if I can't figure out how to be
more productive than I can't take more
classes Skillshare is offering the
michael knowles show listeners a limited
offer of three months of Skillshare for
just 99 cents
you should you really should take this
it is practically free and it's a
wonderful resource I really recommended
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
michael 99 that's my rap name by the way
is michael 99 go to Skillshare calm
slash michael mi CH AE l 99 to get three
months of Skillshare for only 99 cents
you can't afford not to do it act now
for this special New Year's offer it is
going to go away at some point
you will know not the time or the hour
start learning today Skillshare comm
slash michael 99 ladies thank you so
much for being here happy Women's March
Ally President Trump tweeted on the
morning of the women's March quote
beautiful weather all over our great
country a perfect day for all women to
March get out there now to celebrate the
historic milestones an unprecedented
economic success and wealth creation
that has taken place over the last 12
months lowest female unemployment in 18
years is there anything for women to be
upset about in America in 2018 I what
they were celebrating I saw so many
clever signs that celebrated the surging
economy and the low women's unemployment
didn't you there were varying dollar
bills not vagina cause a lot more apps
not only do women not have anything to
complain about an American 2018 but we
really do have so much to celebrate I
just I don't buy this whole
intersectional farce that we are all
split up based on our unique oppression
and that we're not united by anything
good and that's why I think feminism is
cancer not just to women but to the
country in general because women aren't
allowed to celebrate the same things
that benefit men we don't see economic
success I guess is something that is
special to women but we have to break
down our oppression to something that's
specific to our race to our gender to
our socio-economic background in what
they're refusing to see is the unity
that President Trump has actually
accomplished through his policies
and the interesting thing is I was on
HLN and I was speaking to a co-organizer
last week and I asked her which policy
specifically are you protesting and she
said anti-choice the gender wage gap and
criminal justice reform well the problem
with that is none of those things are
policies they're not policies I don't
even know any policies that President
Trump has put forth that has been in
opposition to those things and this was
a co-organizer of the women's March so
they really they really do not know what
they are marching for against not in a
tangible sense it's like what you said
just completely frivolous and nebulous
this intangible sense that they are
dealing with injustice it's my central
theory of the left which is that they
want the appearance of the thing the
form of the thing but not the essence of
it so they want to look like those
really cool marchers back in the 1960s
and didn't they look so cool so we're
gonna do that - what are you marching
for what do we want I don't know when do
you want it whenever that's basically
what it's become amber have we reached
peak feminism or women realizing that
feminism is a pack of lies as Ali was
describing that will just destroy their
lives or sadly as Lena Dunham the voice
of a generation well here's the problem
and I think you touched on this in your
opening segment which is the women's
March does actually have a platform on
their website but the way that they
market the March is so reduction so
reductionist that people don't even
realize what they're actually marching
for so there's like these pink hats and
there's nice signs about how women are
so powerful and you know anti-trump and
also of course some very vulgar signs
which stood in stark contrast to the
March for Life the day prior but women
just go out there because they're told
if they don't that they're anti-woman
that there are bad women and that's why
you have men out there who of course are
trying to support their wives and their
girlfriends who have told them that if
they don't go that they're complicit
with the patriarchy so it's all boiled
down to this this pro-women March but no
one can really define what exactly that
means so it's hard for me to say that
feminism has reached a breaking point
just yet when people don't realize what
exactly they're marching for when they
go out for an organization like this
which in reality is just like hard left
progressive policies
but I will say I was a little bit
surprised when and that lore'l had this
model come in she was a hijab model she
was actually modeling for a hair
campaign which is one of the silliest
things I've ever heard because obviously
you can't see her hair but we uncovered
some anti-israel tweets that she had
made back in 2014 and she was pretty
quickly removed from being a
spokesperson for l'oréal which was
incredibly surprising to me because you
have these leaders of the women's March
who are consistently very anti-israel
and pro-palestine mmm and something you
said in particular that is surprising is
that's a sign of hope something that in
particular you said it really sticks
with me is being complicit in the
patriarchy that is the slogan of our
show the Michael no licit in the
patriarchy so that I got to write that
down that's a that's a nice good
marketing material Ali what do you think
you're you're a you'd you're a
conservative millennial you you are very
much involved in the culture is the
culture turning against feminism or is
that just wishful thinking are we just
stuck in our own conservative bubbles
yeah I think it's hard to say I think
we're going to see in the polls which is
actually something to their credit that
they did emphasize a lot now we'll see
if their emphasis on actually going out
to vote will work during the midterms
and of course in 2020 but I think that's
where we're going to see our answer to
is all of this marching the celebrity
influence this crazy bias in the media
towards the women's March and towards
intersectional feminism and Linda
Sarsour and all of this crazy stuff is
that actually going to translate into
votes for the Democratic Party and I'm
just not sure because you read off some
of those stats and that really the
majority of Americans aren't represented
by these far-left policies that the
women's March is pushing for so are
people actually going to be swayed by
the vagina costume where people who had
to be swayed by the crude posters of
well I won't even go into all that I
don't know it'll be interesting to see
on the one hand on the one hand I do
think that the celebrity influence kind
of gives them perhaps an upper hand on
the other hand
on the other hand I think that
Millennials are um we're not as
impressed with celebrity anymore and
we're kind of turned off by it in a way
so I do I think that actually that could
also do them a disservice
um so I know that's not a clear answer
what I think that we're gonna see is
just how we vote and if we vote and in
the midterms it's hard for me to say
because of course I am
I'm denouncing it and I am NOT a
feminist and I didn't go Marsh but
that's me is that gonna be the pitch for
a new show on CR TV look I'm not a
feminist I'm a millennial I'm is that
how's the show going to prep the show
prep and everything to tell us a little
bit about it before we hand over to do
yes it will be launching on the 29th
which is next week I'll be going to DC
to meet all of my see our TV peeps on
the 30th for the State of the Union will
be doing a live show all together on
that night but all of my videos and
stuff will come out next week as well so
thanks for X yeah I look forward to it I
obviously I had actually deleted CR T V
from my browser or my computer wouldn't
even go to it when it was just Crowder
and then now that you're there roaming
is going over there I guess maybe I'll
have to complete yes I guess so so we're
gonna talk about the March for Life
which is like the opposite of the
women's March it's just it has a point
it's very life-affirming it's this
wonderful thing it actually coincides
and aligns with the opinions of the vast
majority of American women but if you're
just on Facebook and YouTube I'm sorry
folks you got to go to daily wire.com to
do it if you're already a member thank
you you helped keep the lights on you
keep khofifah in my cup it's really nice
if you go to daily wired.com right now
you will get me you get the Andrew
Klavan show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you'll get the conversation and you can
ask questions I think I'm up next
so you can log-in and ask questions in
the mailbag and you can ask questions
during the conversation you get no ads
on the website yeah right enough of that
enough of that what do you really get
you get this I I want like a little pink
hat on top of the leftist years tumblr
this is the day to do it folks the
anniversary of Roe be waiting it the
whole country is turning pro-life
we've got the women shrieking my luckily
I had my official daily wire earbuds in
so they didn't pop my eardrums over the
weekend and I had my leftist tears
tumblr to collect all of their salty
salty delicious and incoherent tears so
go to daily wired.com right now you've
got to get it we'll be right back
[Music]
the March for Life took place last
Friday today is the anniversary of roe
v-- wade which invented some
constitutional right to abortion that I
don't ever really remember Alexander
Hamilton or James Madison writing about
but they found it there somewhere Ali
will we see an end to legal abortion in
our lifetimes I don't know I don't know
and I think roe v wade was a horrible
decision and I don't think it was
constitutional like you said I think he
completely made up an inference from the
14th amendment that had no found in what
the founders actually meant it's a
little you kind of hope that we'll go
back to our constitutional roots and
that a bad decision will one day be
reversed but it seems like we're going
away from the Constitution wholesale
anyway so it's hard for me to believe
that we will go back on this decision
but of course I mean that that is my
hope that even if even if it was just a
20-week ban even if we just made headway
in that direction I would be happy and I
think that might be possible because I
think Trump actually just made some sort
of announcement to to that end but I
don't I don't have confidence that we
will ban abortion altogether in our
lifetime and the pro-abortion left they
always talk about rape incest life of
the mother all three of those cases of
abortion constitute less than one
percent of annual abortions so that's
fine you want an exception for that I
could compromise on that if I could get
rid of 99% of abortions tomorrow and
ironically we were told Donald Trump is
this lifelong politically not quite
clear sort of a Democrat playboy from
Queens he's perhaps the most pro-life
president we've ever had he's the first
u.s. president to address the March for
Life which itself is the the longest
continuous protest in American history
he's been very good on pro-life and we
can only hope that he'll push to just
etched away at the edges maybe we can't
overturn roe v wade tomorrow but we can
push those bans a little
further back we can get more originalist
Sanh the court and we can we can work
toward that as the March for Life has
done for four decades Amber compare and
contrast the March for life to the
women's March the former seemed to me
was life-affirming joyful triumphant
really nice
the latter was miserable shrieking and
laced with profanity as just a matter of
marketing who on earth would want to go
to the women's March what kind of people
is it attracting and turning off yeah
well I mean you pretty much just summed
it up the March for Life no was that a
loaded question I don't it was a really
happy like fun time obviously people had
really nice signs no one was screaming
at each other and then you go to the
women's March and you have women who's
simultaneously claimed that Trump is
debasing the office of the president
while holding up signs with curse words
and vaginas drawn on them so it's kind
of unreal and actually the the point was
demonstrated pretty clearly to me last
year I went to both last year I didn't
make it this year but I was riding on
the Metro on the way to the women's
March to cover it for I was working at
campus to form at the time and I
actually ended up getting berated by a
random man on the metro when he found
out that I was a conservative pro-life
woman and to the credit of the women
around him they were very shocked at the
way that he was you know talking to a
woman it was very much what one might
call mansplaining but just I've never
seen something like that in March for
life I've never seen you know pro-life
people offer anything but love and
acceptance and you know they're never
judgmental about women who choose to get
abortions they just they're always
talking about the message of love and
how you know women are best served by
accepting them and loving them despite
whatever mistakes that they've made and
the women's March is just all it's it's
about you know there are certain women
that are wrong that have internalized
misogyny
that need to be reallocated and you saw
this with Cecile Richards calling out
specifically white women who are at the
March and how they need to do more work
before they are truly feminist and just
just for the viewers who don't aren't
familiar with Cecile Richards she is the
the maniacal ghoul who
300,000 babies a year as the head of
Planned Parenthood so if you answer who
makes hundreds of thousands of dollars
profits off of the sale of their parts
and their organs in their limbs that
woman that's the sale Richards and I
think the women's march in their quest
for intersectionality they end up
actually becoming much more divisive
than they originally intended because
someone's plate is always worse than
someone else's plate so yeah you're
black woman so you must have it harder
than a white woman but oh here's a
transgender black woman who's missing
your left hand and all of a sudden
you've lost the oppression of a snake
starts eating its own tail and this is
to an aspect in the March for Life these
people are protesting the slaughter of
innocent babies they have a clear
purpose they have a clear objective and
it's pretty serious but they're joyful
about it and it's because they have a
seriousness of purpose and they're
really doing something the women's March
are griping about absolutely nothing
they cannot describe what they're
protesting but they're shrieking
vulgarities because that's the only
thing bouncing around their empty heads
and very often we see this in political
debate people who don't know what
they're talking about or know what
they're doing they get crazed and
hysterical and the people who do have a
purpose and a seriousness of purpose or
a bit joyful because they're they're
pointed toward the good they're doing
something that has a purpose and they're
going to achieve it and not let their
own craziness get in the way of that you
know speaking of totally purposeless
things the government reopened again and
no we didn't give amnesty to the illegal
aliens and we didn't give up on the wall
but Democrats shut down the government
last week and then they reopened it
today without gaining anything Ali what
was the point of this government
shutdown the point of the government
shutdown was for Schumer to flex the
muscles and for them to be able to use
the rhetoric that Bernie Sanders has
already made over the weekend I predict
I knew was going to happen they're going
to continue it through the midterms is
they're going to say look the government
shut down I told you that Republicans
were completely unable to govern they
haven't been able to govern anything
since Trump took office they made you
all these promises they haven't been
able to do it and they shut down the
government because they don't care about
illegal
which we know is totally not true at all
Trump can't vote in the Senate we know
that's a lie but they are going to
continue that line of rhetoric can tell
the midterms to say that Republicans
cannot govern I think that was the
entire purpose of it I've always thought
that Democrats wanted to shut down the
government so they can use that
messaging going into the midterms I
think that's what they'll do yeah I
think you're right there's so much more
to talk about there's just one last bit
we're gonna have to skip ahead a little
because we're running late today the
International Monetary Fund announced
today that it expects global economic
growth to exceed predictions largely
because of Republican tax reform amber
the better things seem to be going the
more hysterical the left seems to get
why is that why are why are they
reacting in exactly the opposite way
that you would suspect well it's really
sad I think just in general liberals and
Democrats to some extent are so anti
Trump that they put the failure of
President Trump over the success of the
country they would rather see president
Trump's presidency implode they'd rather
see the government shutdown they'd
rather see Robert Muller's investigation
prove Russian collusion and impeach
Trump than they would for you know
everyday Americans to get $1,000 tax cut
it's just pathetic and they've gotten to
this hysteria to this point that they're
they're selling such heavy partisan
politics except they can't be happy for
any successes in this country as long as
Trump is out there and even more than
that obviously they're dedicated to
their political goals and their agenda
but they're so devoted to their
narrative that when reality contradicts
their narrative as it has they deny
reality they deny their lyin eyes
because the narrative is more important
so they predict that the economy will
tank if Donald Trump is elected they
predict he'll become an authoritarian
they predict the this that and the other
thing it will clamp down on rights for
everybody none of that has happened the
opposite has happened they say he'll be
a terribly obscure president they won't
let the press do anything it's the most
transparent administration in modern
presidential history and yet they have
to believe the narrative you see this on
the
left obviously and even among anti-trump
Republicans they they're so committed to
that narrative but it's very important
the one thing we know about politics is
you're never gonna get it right
especially the thing we know about
Donald Trump is the guy is a complete
wild card and if you make a prediction
about him you're probably going to be
proven wrong so that the narrative
aspect of all of it the ideological
aspect of all of it is really not
helpful to the ideologue sit puts
blinders on them and I think they're
missing the reality that that's right in
front of us but that's why they gotta
stay tuned and enjoy the cafe if you
just enjoy the cafe you're gonna see the
world a lot more clearly ladies thank
you for being here that's all the time
we have ally Stuckey her new show is
starting up soon I'm sure we'll talk to
her again before that all starts and
amber Athey great to have them both
that's our whole show today I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
come back tomorrow we'll do it all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
Hague
supervising producer Mathis Glover our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jeshua alvera the Michael nul show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017